meanwhile his teammates and victims
families will try to cope with this
tragedy sports director chris matthews
has more now on what the raiders are
saying this afternoon chris joining us
live in studio well thank you very much
brian yeah football is so insignificant
during this time of tragedy it's hard to
imagine what's going on in the minds of
the players right now as they try to
prepare for a game this sunday raiders
headquarters parking lot was full of
cars this afternoon and one can only
imagine the conversations going on
behind the steel bars and inside that
facility shock over the player involved
in a preventable accident that took the
life of another human being it's no
longer about football we caught up with
former nfl quarterback randall
cunningham who is the pastor at remnant
ministries he's also the raiders team
chaplain
uh what's happened it's a tragedy uh but
we just gotta really be encouraging to
both families and uh yes he's got a
little girl so
um
you know as a pastor and as a chaplain
of the raiders i'm available to you know
just encourage them and encourage both
families
all right both families will need some
help certainly the raiders did release a
statement this morning which reads in
part we are devastated by the loss of
life and our thoughts and prayers go out
to the victims family we are in the
process of gathering information and
will have no further comment at this
time cunningham has had rugs over and
many other raiders over to his ministry
in the past he is also sending his
sincerest condolences to the victims
families denise